so as we mentioned thousands almost 300
000 clark county school district
students head back to class today it's a
new school year and we have team
coverage this morning ron futrell is
over at bonanza high school this morning
because in a few minutes there's going
to be some pretty special guests over on
campus we're going to start though with
christian kazadis live this morning at
the arville transportation yard bus
drivers christian i assume they're
already out on their first routes
they are john that's right good morning
the sun is out and of course it's the
first day of school for so many students
for ccsd and everything starts right
here with the rollout of the school
buses take a look some of those empty
spots already are from the buses that
just
left the yard here you have one of them
just making it their way out of this
area you also have a couple of other
maintenance crews bus drivers doing the
last minute checks on the vehicles
before they start their route again
we're here at the arville transportation
yard near arville and harmon and this is
just one of several hubs for the school
district's 1900 bus fleet now it's a big
task for these workers because they
cover over 1300 routes around the valley
now in the last half hour we spoke to
desiree denton as she got ready to start
her third year as a school bus driver
she wants to remind all parents to be
vigilant on the roads she says the first
week of school tends to have many
parents confused and that can sometimes
cause traffic issues and even accidents
she is one of hundreds of bus drivers
taking on this huge task covering so
many routes on the first day of class
more nervous than anything
of course we did our dry runs and
everything so we know where everything
is is that we're supposed to be picking
up today
but you never know especially with the
parents in the areas that we're going to
be in now compared to
like there's air friday
very exciting time here of course on
this first day of school now i can tell
you the superintendent just arrived
along with his transportation staff and
we hope to speak to him about the
planning that goes behind the first day
of school and all the goals that he has
as thousands of students head back to
the classrooms on this monday morning
and of course we hope to have that
information for you coming up at 6 30.
christian casa is live local now there